by stating our New Year's resolutions oh
man well I'm gonna tell you guys
something that I saw a documentary
called walk with me that's not okay it
is a new year's resolution and it's
about this um Vietnamese dude not dad I
love him but it was a Vietnamese dude
and it's his name is uh thick not Han
and he's a monk and he has a monastery
in France and it's in France yeah people
give their lives to the monster they
shave their heads and they live there
and they work on the land and when it
wait so you're what the [ __ ] are you New
Year's resolution is to be a mom no but
what I'm saying is is that no when I was
watching the documentary that I could
see myself as a monk like doing what on
a daily I would wake up when everyone
else wakes up right with the Sun with
the song the Sun wakes yeah yeah and I
would make the black tea Steve if you
look at me right now why are you smiling
and why are you smiling so there's black
tea I hope it said and then I would take
a rake with my other brothers and I
would rake the land I would you know
leaves Norrish don't laugh tell it to
get that's exactly what I was gonna say
that's exactly what I was going to say
earlier that would be the Tillett you
are so attached to technology you're so
attached you know and that's another
thing that you're so negative
no I'm just being real that's a fact ah
brother I know Papa no cuz you every
time in Gilbert he was literally either
like even worse we played battlefront 2
by the way we're in Arizona good games
out to my mom and dad we're in Arizona
and for I'm telling you for 15 hours a
day
battlefront battlefront battlefront yeah
we'd switch off if he died I'd take over
you know we but he couldn't even towards
the end he couldn't wait from my he
would he wouldn't watch me play he'd go
on to his other device so it was either
here or he was like doing that or you
know I mean so no you wouldn't because
I'm not a monk now
so what is your new year's resolution
and why did you tell this story because
I think that I'm gonna rake leaves
tomorrow he's gonna tell no no I I might
I'm gonna I'm gonna go online to see if
that they have like a class not a class
but like a non-committal thing that I
can do where I can stay there for like
three months what do we do a retreat
yeah retreat my head for you no no I
know devices nothing just wake up I'm
gonna shave my head ball even if they
say that I don't need to keep her hair I
need to do the look I need to do these
long long walks with hung yeah through
the forest and um they don't talk much
and it's so funny that you guys provoke
me in that way and doubt me because um
12 years ago not 12 years ago 22 years
ago my bad I went to a monastery and I
lived there for a month
I know if you remember that in San Diego
no yeah no it was in Santa Barbara but
my my dad Arwen an old sponsor yeah yeah
they we took we went to a monastery I
didn't shave my head but I remember not
talking and I remember it being one of
the most peaceful times in my life well
that's cool man so didn't I do for three
months I think you could do it Yeah
right I thought he meant like a life
change
[Music]